hallo deutsch schule training singular
[Musik]
mehrzahl
singular der hund der
hund
plural die
hunde die
hunde
ich habe ein klein süßen hund er heißt
max
ich habe
ein klein süßen hund er heißt max
ich habe sogar drei süße kleine hunde
sie heißen jimmy johnny und joker ich
habe sogar drei süße kleine hunde sie
heißen jimmy johnny und joker
mein hund max welt immer wenn er hungrig
ist mein hund max welt immer wenn er
hungrig ist
meine hunde jimmy johnny und joker denn
immer wenn sie eine katze sehen
hast du auch ein hund
singular das haus
das haus
plural die
häuser die
häuser
das haus ist sehr hoch es ist ein so
genanntes
hochhaus
das haus ist sehr hoch es ist ein so
genanntes
hochhaus die häuser in meiner straße
sehen alle gleich aus sie haben dieselbe
architektur die häuser in meiner straße
architektur
das haus hat ein wunderschön grün garten
das haus hat einen wunderschön grün
garten in vielen deutschen großstädten
gibt es sehr viele hochhäuser
in vielen deutschen großstädten
wohnst du in einem haus oder in einer
wohnung
singular die
universität die universität
plural die
universitäten die
universitäten
jawohl ich wurde an der universität
angenommen die jawohl ich wurde an der
universität
angenommen
in deutschland gibt es viele
verschiedene
universitäten in deutschland
gibt es viele verschiedene
universitäten
die abkürzung für
universität
lautet uni ich gehe zur uni die
abkürzung für universität laute toni ich
gehe zur uni die chemie studenten
studieren an der technischen universität
sie studieren an der tu die chemie
studenten studieren an der technischen
universität
sie studieren an der tu
kennst du auch eine deutsche universität
singular das auto das auto
plural die autos die autos
das
polizeiauto fährt mit blaulicht das
polizeiauto fährt mit blaulicht
momentan sind elektroautos in
deutschland sehr beliebt
mein auto hat leider eine panne ich
telefoniere
gerade mit dem pannendienst mein auto
hat leider eine panne ich telefoniere
gerade mit dem pannendienst auf
der autobahn gibt es ein stau alle autos
müssen warten auf der autobahn gibt es
ein stau alle autos müssen warten wie
findest du
elektroautos
singular das hemd das hemd
plural die hemden die händen
zu einem
hemd trägt man meistens eine krawatte
oder eine fliege zu einem hemd trägt man
meistens eine krawatte oder eine fliege
es gibt rote hemden
gelbe hemden
grüne hemden und bunte hemden es gibt
rote hemden gelbe hemden grüne hemden
und bunte hemden
das hier oben ist der sogenannte
hemdkragen
heute ist wieder waschtag ich muss alle
meine hemden waschen
meine hemden waschen wann ist bei dir
immer waschtag
singular die nuss die nuss
plural die nüsse die nüsse
immer wenn ich eine kokosnuss sehe denke
ich an die karibik immer wenn ich eine
kokosnuss sehe denke ich an die karibik
es gibt harte walnüsse und
gesalzene erdnüsse und
karibische kokosnüsse es gibt harte
walnüsse und
gesalzene erdnüsse und
karibische kokosnüsse guck mal das
eichhörnchen hat eine leckere nuss
gefunden guck mal das eichhörnchen hat
eine leckere nuss gefunden
manche nüsse sind von einer schale
umgeben
welche nüsse isst du am liebsten
singular das foto das foto
plural die
fotos die
fotos der tourist macht im urlaub ein
foto mit seinem fotoapparat
der tourist macht im urlaub ein foto mit
seinem fotoapparat
bei uns zu hause hängen viele schöne
fotos an der wand bei uns zu hause
hängen viele schöne fotos an der wand
guck mal auf diesem foto hier ist unser
hund noch ganz klein
fotos helfen mir dabei mich an die
vergangenheit zu erinnern
hast du ein lieblingsfoto aus der
vergangenheit
singular der apfel der apfel
plural die äpfel die äpfel
mein arzt sagt ich soll jeden tag einen
apfel essen
die roten äpfel schmecken mir
eindeutig besser als die grünen äpfel
die roten äpfel schmecken mir eindeutig
besser als die grünen äpfeln
messe ich lieber ein apfel eine birne
oder eine banane
esse ich lieber ein apfel eine birne
oder eine banane in
diesem korb sind viele köstliche äpfel
aus meinem garten
in diesem korb sind viele köstliche
äpfel aus meinem garten
ist du auch täglich einen apfel
singular der lehrer der lehrer
plural die lehrer die lehrer
die lehrerin für physik ist die
physiklehrerin die
lehrerin für physik ist die
physiklehrerin
im lehrerzimmer
bereiten sich die lehrer auf den
unterricht vor im lehrerzimmer
unterricht vor ein guter lehrer ist beim
deutsch lernen sehr wichtig ein guter
lehrer ist beim deutsch lernen sehr
wichtig
viele lehrer
unterrichten an einem gymnasium oder an
einer grundschule
viele lehrer
unterrichten an einem gymnasium oder an
einer grundschule
wärst du auch gerne ein lehrer
singular der stift der
stift
plural die stifter die stifte
zum schreiben benutze ich immer gerne
einen blauen stift zum schreiben benutze
ich immer gerne ein blauer stift
ich habe verschiedene stifte in
unterschiedlichen farben zur auswahl ich
habe verschiedene stifte in
unterschiedlichen farben zur auswahl
wenn ich unsicher bin dann schreibe ich
meistens mit dem bleistift wenn ich
unsicher bin dann schreibe ich meistens
mit dem bleistift
bunte stifte zum malen nennt man
buntstifte bunte stifte zum malen nennt
man buntstifte
besitzt du eigentlich ein lieblings
stift
singular die vase die vase
plural die
vasen die vasen die vase für die blumen
nennt man
blumenvase die vase für die blumen nennt
man
blumenvase
ich habe viele bunte
blumenvasen zu hause ich habe viele
bunte blumenvasen zu hause
die sonnenblumen stehen in der vase die
sonnenblumen stehen in der vase die
tulpen stehen in einer edlen design vase
die tulpen stehen in einer edlen design
vase hast du auch eine blumenvase zu
hause
tipp lerne die vokabeln in der einzahl
und in der mehrzahl
abonniere den kanal der halo deutsch
schule und aktiviere das kleine
glöckchen
gib uns jetzt ein daumen nach oben und
klicke auf diese playlist für weitere
videos zum deutsch lernen